[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything dies
looking for you surprised so season 2
it's coming July 2nd and it's called
battle charge but what you can expect
from the launch is a new legend I do
weapon a new way to play the game ok
perhaps a map event and a lot of this
has been done through a lot of feedback
from community we're also changing up
some of the meta balance of weapons to
try and buff up some of the weaker
weapons and bring a lot of cool stuff
again
[Music]
your ignorance meets your end
[Applause]
good job me a new season strong work
well ladies gentlemen the moment has
arrived the 10th legend joining the apex
legendre's arena is Watson pretended to
mocha pour toujours
papa
I did I hope wherever you are you're
cheering for me the Watson has more
interrelated abilities than probably any
other current character we have you
really need to understand how they all
interact the fences you can place 12
nodes and you can use these in any
permutation you want part of why we sort
of went was that her being such a
brilliant electrical engineer is because
we really want to reinforce both
mechanically and thematically how
creative the player can be with these
a timeless theater of war a new vision
prepared to deploy to the Pacific the
team at dice are hard at work creating
an iconic World War 2 experience
releasing this fall with chapter 5 of
battlefield 5 as the US and Japan
enter the fight your clash across
several battlefields including a modern
take on an absolute classic
Iwo Jima since battlefield began the
Pacific Theater has been part of its DNA
now we're crafting the ultimate
reimagining of the conflict by capturing
real-life environments and using the
power of frostbite we're bringing you
the Pacific realized with today's
capabilities and technology take part in
the u.s. invasions as they're
unstoppable forces charged inland
towards unwavering Japanese defenses use
new amphibious units to pummel the war
ridden shores and an expanded arsenal to
bring your squad to victory
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've always loved competing and to me
there's no added pressure there's no
added expectations that stuff that I put
on myself since I was a little kid I
feel like I'm just that same guy that's
been putting the time and the work my
whole entire life now it's about pushing
myself every single day to get better
it's about passion I'm going out there
having fun you have to make sure that
you're just evolving never being
satisfied with where you're at coming
into the league it seems like every
single year there's some different guy
that's just faster and stronger and
bigger and so with the find different
ways to get better and those are the
guys that find ways to win in the end
every single year from college to come
into league and as my career goes on I
just keep getting better and better at
the approach for me to play and
recognize what you can do it have
success the first time I ever ran out
the tunnel in front of that crowd it was
a surreal feeling and I'll never forget
it my expectation was to win a Super
Bowl and I fell just short of that you
used that stuff as motivation this is
just the beginning
[Music]
we have the next expansion pack for The
Sims 4 Sims 4 Island living
[Music]
please welcome Bethesda's senior global
vice president of marketing Pete Hines
if you're ready let's kick it off and to
get an update from our friends at one of
the most celebrated development studios
in the world
please welcome studio head and my good
friend Todd Howard we have had an
incredibly exciting year Bethesda Game
Studios given some of that excitement
impressed you're still here take Fallout
76 a type of game we've never done
before
had a lot of difficulties at launch and
we got a lot of well-deserved criticism
hi I'm project leader Jeff Gardner and
I'm Co studio director Tom Mustaine
we've also been working on our biggest
update yet
it's called wastelanders and it will
fundamentally change the game it's been
some time since vault 76 opened its door
I don't think any of us expected for
people to actually come back are you
from that vault
can you help us
question is are you with us with them
yeah we put a battle royale in fallout
76
tonight I am excited to announce the
next game from tango course wire Tokyo
it is an action-adventure game in which
you will fight paranormal enemy and the
greatest city of a supernatural evil
it's Turkey
[Music]
we can add finger and now for something
completely different
[Music]
I just want to shout out to our friend
Greg they're the one in the video that
really loves dragons I'm happy to say
Greg the Elder Scrolls online has
dragons
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all around it is destructibility pants
and women red barrel dropping we
[Music]
[Applause]
Secaucus wait
[Music]
first we are bringing Nazi killing into
virtual reality with Wolfenstein spy
behind and if you haven't put Nazis in
VR you don't know what you are missing
and in young lot
you can kill those daughters with a
friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's places in the paradise
[Music]
out here out here we travel free in this
endless eternal cycle death loop
combines a mind-bending story with
meticulously designed levels and of
course arcane signature gameplay that
lets you approach every situation anyway
like because in the endless clash
between these two extraordinary
assassins how you play is up to you plus
I think it's ready
cool
[Applause]
[Music]
tongue is on Martha everybody could use
a little more doom in their lives the
fun comes from mastering the experience
because you are the doom Slayer the
strongest fastest demon killer in
existence and nothing can stand in your
way
[Music]
[Music]
from the thousands of games in
development across Xbox one and Windows
PC were highlighting 60 games for you
[Music]
the feeling of of being there of walking
the streets of the future is really
going to be breathtaking
[Applause]
we are thrilled to share at the Xbox
game pass for PC launches in open beta
today try it out by downloading the all
new Xbox app on Windows and if you want
it all we have created a membership just
for you Xbox game pass ultimate Xbox
game pass for console with over 100
great games Xbox Live Gold an unrivaled
gaming community and now Xbox game pass
for PC at no additional charge
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when we think about the future of gaming
it's not just PC it's not just console
it's not just mobile it's really all of
the above Xbox is all about choice we're
investing in technology all throughout
the game stack we put the fan at the
center of every decision we make the
games you want with the people you want
on the devices that you want and for us
that starts with our next-generation
console we don't want to build just
another console we truly want it to be
transformative more immersion more
exploration more detail how do we make
it easier for people to get into they
came to stay in the game one of the
things that gamers and developers are
incredibly excited about is reducing
load times I'm an RPG gamer and so like
loading screens are thing sitting there
in the fake elevator because you know
that the games loading in the background
there's just an elevator ride forever
that's our goal with gaming is that you
don't have those pauses this generation
is special because we've really unlocked
this new capability to connect with the
characters and worlds in a way that no
previous generation has allowed this
generation is going to be a bigger leap
than any generation we've done before at
the heart of our next-generation console
is our custom design processor
leveraging the latest Zen - and Navi
technology from our partners at AMD from
a pure processing perspective this is
four times more powerful than the Xbox
one X we're leveraging high bandwidth G
DDR 6 to ensure that we're getting the
best performance possible it's gonna
occur in resolution and frame rates that
we've never seen before like never seen
before we're looking at frame rates up
to 120 frames per second 8k capability
variable refresh rate next-gen ray
tracing it's real time because this
hardware accelerated for the first time
ever what I'm personally most excited
about is the SSD we've created a new
generation of SSDs we're actually using
the SSD as virtual Ram we're seeing more
than 40 times performance increases over
the current generation the combination
of the SSD and the solid state drive are
really what gives you a totally new
experience now we can take all of that
power and apply it back into the scene
so we can actually generate more life in
that world and bring it to the gamer in
a seamless way so that then you're fully
experiencing what the game developer
wants you to experience when you can
move through worlds without waiting for
screens to low that speed that
performance is what the next generation
is about this is the most immersive
console experience ever what we really
want to do is give developers the power
to build the game they've always
envisioned we have hundreds of people
across both our first party studios as
well as our third party Studios working
on those next generation experiences
today it's an amazing commitment to
content at Xbox game studios 13 Studios
7 in the last year
that's a big family at 343 for us it's
always about more seamless worlds with
the next generation we can bring the
world to life in a way we've never
experienced halo before we're delivering
four generations of content better than
you've ever seen them before this
console is especially awesome for game
pass members with the faster load times
you're gonna be able to experience all
the games within just snap your fingers
we are giving gamers the option to
connect across devices and across
platforms in a way that we never were
able to before I don't lose my
last generation as I move into the next
generation the people I play with in the
games that I want to play that
experience should be continuous to know
it's growing this isn't just a console
launch this is about the future of
gaming your games your achievements your
progression your accessories your
console gaming experience with Xbox it
all comes forward with Scarlett
in watchdog's legion your mission is to
build a popular resistance to fight back
against the emergence of an
authoritarian regime this means you
don't just play as one hero but many and
in watchdog's legion you can recruit and
play as anyone can find that drawing
expert he's about to get himself
Wesley oh just ignore me
[Music]
lost Ian he's gone hello darling
[Applause]
[Music]
time to go they'll be on to me is this
Amin despair on your feet mate oh wait a
minute are you good sick hope you're
sharper than you look
Jesus Christ
[Music]
they find themselves on the precipice of
their first major expansion
banquet what is this it's a commercial
for the game it's a commercial for you
it's still going we realized very early
on that if we were going to do this we
wanted to do it right and to be as
authentic as possible because as you all
know nobody smells [ __ ] like this
particular community
[Music]
[Music]
hey I'm John good to be here this is
bambam the dog thank you thank you it's
a real honor to be here with you guys
today thank you I love you too right on
this is awesome you know I've had the
chance to play some pretty strong tough
men over the years I've played a deputy
fighting zombies special Special Forces
soldier who lost everything and now I
get to play a coldie Walker he's a
skilled former Special Operations
soldier with his own sense of
responsibility his own moral code these
ghosts they over the past they still
served the machine that we left behind
right now for the future the world needs
us strikes
the specialists
[Music]
all four great lachemann
great
warranty will test your tactical skills
and survival instincts holding you and
your operators on the razor's edge the
training doesn't prepare you to on
someone you used to call brother
he has left us no other choice if we
don't stop him
there will be nothing left to save
so we started working on roller
champions a skill-based
team pvp sports game that is as fun to
watch as it is to play a game in which
you the player can create your own story
as you roll up to glory
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the stories of the ancient gods and
their misadventures have existed through
generations of storytellers and
audiences and I've transformed into
tales that we still know and love today
[Music]
remaking Final Fantasy seven has allowed
us to dive much deeper into the world
and its characters than ever before the
game design was optimised for this title
as well and we anticipate to blu-ray
discs worth of gameplay content of
course this being a remake we're sure to
see some familiar faces
[Music]
hold on to that hatred
[Music]
[Music]
we describe outriders as the dark model
shooter build with traditional bodies by
that I mean we are creating an
experience with a strong story that you
can enjoy with your friends or on your
own never meet your heroes
Wow
I did
[Applause]
and it was awesome
the Avengers were everything I imagined
to bring this incredible story to life
we've assembled an all-star cast I'll
let them introduce themselves hi I'm
Troy Baker and I play Bruce Banner hi
I'm Jeff shine and I played Captain
America
I'm travis willingham and I play Thor hi
I'm Lori Bailey and I'm playing Black
Widow
I have Nolan North I play Tony Stark
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now sign konichiwa hello everyone i'm
Yoshiaki Koizumi from Nintendo in this
Nintendo Direct for e3 2019 we'll
showcase a variety of games
many of them coming soon but before we
dig in to the next game there is someone
I'd like to introduce first what what
are you doing here wait wait wait wait
wait a minute there's been a bit of a
mix-up oh you're not the right Bowser
sorry but I'm the right Bowser for this
presentation
[Music]
not this way no no this way
maybe next time
are you related
no but we'd get that a lot well let's
get back to it please take it away
hi everyone I'm Doug Bowser from
Nintendo of America and I'm thrilled to
join you for today's Nintendo Direct
this is our chance to show the world we
have games for every type of player on
Nintendo's switch whether you love
action RPGs or you're just looking for
something new we've got you covered okay
so let's get a look at one of those
games by taking a tour of Luigi's
Mansion three
I know Luigi's invited to a gorgeous
hotel with Mario peach and the others oh
lucky him
the Luigi's Mansion free
this hotel is much more than meets the
guy for not long after Luigi arrives
things take a dark turn we begin our
tour by taking in some sights and sounds
you may never leave one to leave the
other guests certainly don't plan to
move their ghosts after all and their
rather aggressive simply scare them with
the strobe bulb the mop Luigi's new
Poltergust g00 has the powerful suction
capabilities required and are the new
features as well
first the slab while trapping it goes
slam it on the ground inflict some
damage he comes to get other ghosts it
on the actual next the suction shot and
finally the plunger to attach it to
something then pull the screen and you
can destroy furniture and more it's
effective against certain ghost types
too sometimes ghosts may feel inclined
to hang up on you
in such situations of first trip to the
powerful air pressure with least will
blow away ghosts and it's perfect for
when you need a little air ah we simply
can't overlook the latest invention from
Professor egad namely GUI G change
between Luigi and Curie GT use both
their skills GUI G can do everything
from slipping through metal fences to
walking on spikes indeed there are
obstacles too great for the region to
handle on its own and if you pass a toy
con controller to a friend he makes for
a great co-op partner but proceed with
caution
GUI G and water definitely don't mix now
please direct your attention to the
scarce curve
[Music]
online co-op being defeat all ghosts
before time runs out
seek and find our deal misplaced toes
and face any challenges the tower throws
at you
[Music]
[Music]
what a place to wake up in a haunted
hotel with floor after floor of oddities
many traps and mischievous ghosts work
within what will befall our missing
Mario and friends and his dear brother
Luigi
[Music]
[Applause]
Luigi's Mansion 3
[Music]
so that was Luigi's Mansion 3 the latest
game in a series that I personally love
and we can look forward to seeing some
of the new gameplay elements that await
in this strange hotel as we dive deeper
into this title on Nintendo treehouse
live at e3 2019 we'll be streaming
content some you've never seen before
right from the show floor including live
gameplay of Super Mario maker 2 and on
day 3 our treehouse staff will get their
hands on some promising indie games that
are new to Nintendo switch while you
watch today's Nintendo Direct keep an
eye out for this icon to learn what
other games will appear on Nintendo
treehouse live at e3 2019 you won't want
to miss it or this have a look oh oh
far too long seeing your story has
become take darkness spreads but from
this dark
light brighter than the three suns they
sparked the life
heroes of the strong brave strength and
bravery
[Music]
you
[Music]
defeat logistic
[Music]
we're going to need all that amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
action-rpg trials of nana kept getting a
global relief when Intendant wish
[Music]
set destiny in motion with the power of
man
[Music]
trials of mana
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm looking for a woman
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's all agree to meet back at the
monastery exactly five years from today
like a class reunion you will come won't
you
years ago we fought here as classmates
as big class reunions go this one's got
to be the worst in history what should
we do teachers kill every last one of
them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have no choice but to eliminate those
who cling to unreasonable ideas of
justice
someone must put a stop to this cycle of
the strong trembling a weak
[Music]
this was even the doctor say so
yet we have the strength to scale the
walls between us to reach out our hands
friendship so we can open our true
hearts to one another that's how we win
teacher both sides of time
[Music]
how lovely it would be for this moment
to last forever
[Music]
in Kansas Lee to an 10 dose which is the
only gaming console you can play not
only on your TV at home but anywhere you
go got there in fact with a system like
this it might be fun to play Resident
Evil at a location like this
this is perfect right
no lights no lights Hey
okay let's do this
resident evil
can you open them try Swiss through
there
[Applause]
gonna just eat it
so I come back okay okay okay okay
got it
[Applause]
[Applause]
evil playing a Resident Evil game in a
place like that might not be my way to
play but I bet you could find your way
to play don't you think for now please
take a look was today the 4th of July if
not is the Empire striking back or what
looks like things are gonna get
hexie
as you can see things got all funky real
quick there's probably some planet
itazuke waiting for me up ahead all yell
can powerful and try to take over the
world
but don't you worry
what there are no heroes in this world
but they're totally are my name is
Travis touchdown
here to save the world I'm also just a
path
now let's do this start the game welcome
back Travis
- Zig God elephants
Kizer
he led an elite team contrast during war
HB is actually a cyborg
harakiri and her alien gutbucket they
survive by merging together during the
alien
the gentleman the sweetest bug don't
ever meet by Oh
[Music]
[Music]
don't give up begin the mission jerk all
rookie
the battles already started if you get
in our way we will eliminate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
konnichiwa hello I'm Sheena takahashi
from Nintendo earlier this month he held
a Pokemon direct for the latest games in
the series pokemon sword
okay then pokemon shield the developers
from Game Freak showcased the new
gallery the location of your new
adventure and some new Pokemon you'll
encounter there it will be a while until
these games launch so please stay tuned
[Music]
by the way in these games you can use
certain functions of the pokeball plus
accessory allowing you to take a Pokemon
from one of these games out for a stroll
through the real world with you you may
not be able to use the device as a game
controller but if you spend some quality
time with a favorite Pokemon of yours
then something good might happen in the
Nintendo booth at this year's e3 fans
can play pokemon sword and pokemon
shield for the first time anywhere in
the world in this gameplay demo you can
challenge one of the gyms in the gallery
region the one and only water gem where
the water type Gym Leader Nessa
will be there waiting for you if you're
attending this year's show I encourage
you to experience
dynamaxx Pokemon it reaches an advanced
strategy from this region also
immediately after this Nintendo Direct
stay tuned for live gameplay of Pokemon
sword Pokemon shield on the Nintendo
treehouse live and now I'd like to shift
gears please have a look at this
[Music]
I've been waiting for you
earth is currently under
extra-dimensional Tim Paris
like the ones you've just seen for the
first time
[Music]
this rates all of humankind will be
pulled into the
dimension we're facing down the
sweat
research
you finally made it beep ultimate
counter to merit weapon
but neurologically synching captured
Canaris with human operators
this control and made powerful allies
ages
I'll give you some parting advice your
not the blessing you think it is when a
leaky onus and Allegiant are perfectly
synchronized it's like there are two
parts of one body it's impossible and
when half of that
about to die the légion survival
instincts kick in too
there's no way what good could this
possibly be it's a long shot but it's
the only shot we have it's all up to you
a friend a blessing from the
a curse
we can't turn back now
like I know the whole truth
he's still alive out there
I know he is
you
[Music]
[Music]
the Empire
[Music]
death by our house is not an honor they
have burned they deserve something much
worse
[Music]
even with this stone is my command this
may not be a battle we can win whatever
is happening we can beat it
keep fighting
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so what do you think so far now for some
follow-up information on a game that
fans have been waiting for please take a
look your attention please
the new king getaway package charter
flight will soon be arriving at the
deserted island
[Music]
[Music]
originally we announced this title as a
20-19 release however we need to change
its release date to March 20th of 2020
to ensure that the game is the best it
can be
we must ask you to wait a little longer
than we thought
we hope you look forward to the latest
installment of Animal Crossing now on
Nintendo treehouse live the games
producer mr. Nogami
and the director miss kill Goku will
come on for a live demonstration of some
early moments in the game so please
stick around until it starts by the way
there are many different types of games
coming to Nintendo switch from Nintendo
and our partners so we've prepared a
highlight reel to show you what's in
store for 2019 and beyond let's have a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that obviously wasn't duck-hunt
silhouette was it please stay tuned for
more information about DLC in the future
as for Nintendo switch we have more
games and development beyond what we've
shown you today I'm looking forward to
the day we can introduce them to you
speaking of before we end this direct I
actually have one more thing to show you
thank you very much for watching until
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hey good morning everybody and welcome
to e3 2019
I'm Doug Bowser from Nintendo of America
and he is Bill trenin from Nintendo
treehouse we're here from the Nintendo
booth we're gonna spend a couple of
minutes talking about what we just saw
in that Nintendo Direct and we're gonna
give you a sneak peek of the booth so
bill I don't know about you but I think
there's a lot of folks out there that
are pretty excited about what they just
saw
well Doug I think it goes to that
question that I myself am a huge fan of
The Legend of Zelda series like a lot of
people I've put a lot of time into the
breadth of the wild so personally I am
incredibly excited that we're not
getting new DLC we are getting a full
sequel a brand new game in development
for Nintendo switch so hopefully
everyone out there is excited as well
certainly if you're a zelda fan there
was a lot to like in this Nintendo
Direct a lot of other things as well
lots of games for lots of players from
Dragon Quest 11s to even things like
Panzer Dragoon the Dark Crystal
astral chain looking great was there
anything in the direct that stood out to
you for me personally I'm looking
forward to Luigi's Mansion 3 I'm a huge
fan of the series and I look forward to
being able to walk through this the
various levels of this spooky hotel with
my sidekick GUI G and the thing I'm
actually really looking forward to is
the new Poltergust and it's updated
capabilities including the slam move
it's gonna be a lot of fun killing
killing ghosts with killing ghosts with
ghosts that's right and it was really
good yeah I have a feeling this game's
gonna suck up a little bit of my time
you just did that didn't you how was it
that joke sorry you know one other thing
I'm really excited about is is what we
got on the floor here and that is a
pokemon sword and pokemon shield that's
right I think this year is probably the
most space we've ever dedicated in our
booth to a Pokemon game the booth looks
fantastic I think we're gonna go ahead
and take give you a quick sneak peek of
that it's themed on the water gym and
what we've done is we have recreated the
gym leader battle arenas so everybody
here at e3 is going to get a chance to
play pokemon sword and pokemon shield in
the
of the gym leader battle arena and I
think that's gonna be really great for
them but we have something special for
everybody watching live the very first
segment on Nintendo treehouse live this
year at e3 is going to be pokemon sword
and pokemon shield and we're gonna give
people a look at a much bigger part of
that game and I think that the team is
almost ready so I'm gonna head over
there in just a second and we're gonna
get that kicked off fantastic so great
thank you everybody for watching and
stay tuned for some treehouse live
coming up right away
great thanks everyone for viewing make
sure you tune in next for treehouse live
and tune in for the next three days two
treehouse live we'll have discussions
with developers about the games that
they're building we'll give you some
sneak peeks at some first play and we
look forward to giving you a chance to
see everything that we have to offer it
III this year thank you very much hi
everyone welcome to Nintendo treehouse
live 2019 my name is Teresa and we're
here to kick off to the first view of
the live gameplay of pokemon sword and
pokemon shield I'm here with our very
very special guests mr. Matsuda who is
the game producer mr. amore who is the
game director and they're accompanied by
David from the Pokemon company thank you
very much
they're also have a little cameo
appearances of square bunny
Goerke and savile also accompanied by
Terry and Bill who just cartwheel did
too all right so to kick things off
there was a lot of announcements from
the Pokemon direct last week and then
there were some more information that
came out this morning mr. Matsuda mr.
Mori do you have anything to add to
those bad information since it's not a
Nintendo Direct on behind because once I
kill don't know as much as I killed on a
Nintendo Direct aku since it's not
Pokemon directed in Java I didn't Suika
day
Heihachi did like a remaster saganaki
not talks too much to their time ox
stea no densetsu no pokémon Showcase
circuit over digital babe myoga no no no
Sangha so the series on a mediocre
mommas discusses stimulate Arenado
so we're really happy to finally be able
to reveal one of the big features of the
game called Dynomax as well as the
legendary Pokemon I think that's really
getting a lot of the fans out there
excited for the games
yeah I'm actually really really excited
I think we're gonna get a sneak peak to
that element but do you have anything
else that's right I think today was
anything you can share about what we're
gonna be showing on treehouse 5 for
everybody watching at home
Mohandas know from treehouse right a
matter photo mr. Canino super so Dez
Nieto saku-dono directory mom is a typo
no Jim no choice enter photo
Appaji mariano llanera sweetie mark
Hawkeye smashed up the conch I know mark
treehouse arrival devar ma wired area
toe box retreat a designee pledged a
showcase I not oh oh - so on the direct
we just we revealed the water-type Jim
and Jim challenge and the gym leader
Nessa
but in today's treehouse live I want to
demonstrate the actual live gameplay the
wild area as well as max rate battle
gameplay that's right in the wild area
is something that's brand new for the
Pokemon games we have not had an area
like this can you maybe give people just
a little bit of information about what
it is okay why do the idiot McCoy you
I'm a 90s idea do you know come on CDs
demo hajimeta no I cut out a mystical
quest good Satan when I musta Joker
so it's name I know why do area and on
this Kodomo almost two more coconuts
really know okay mom last amassed a
Martin Kahn your demo to get into the
Pokemon record mama Dino forget to
monster sensational Athena who deny
idiot own Optimus so this is really kind
of the first time that we've had such a
huge wide-open area in the Pokemon main
series RPGs and you're in the wild area
really find the widest variety of wild
Pokemon out of any area in the games and
it also changes the Pokemon you can
encounter depending on the weather
conditions and where you go in the time
of day so no machito machi Orton I
didn't or a mohawk gentleman on kaimoana
votos de Luca Toni
Animas a total material that I Krakatoa
chimera cotugno cascada de que uno de
putting your team out which the item
30 solo Thunderhawk a moose a las cuatro
meticulous in the wild area it spans
across multiple town so your adventure
will take you back to this the wild area
multiple times and as you can see on
screen here you can control the camera
freely in this area to better find
hidden items that are lying about and
also see the pokémon that are flying
above in the sky well yes and it looks
like we are seeing Pokemon out in the
field here correct so the most feared Oh
No - Dolores de Leon - junior here in
the syllabus so the snare is on a tikka
taco boy tails from shambhala encounter
they only do ma a dhama encounter to
Otto's domesticated big furry macula
Riddick you know mr. Tomo ha de sibour
Pokemon they are an organic Oh after a
sip ok mama Dell commissary 9000 random
encounter no tequila grunts legitimate
son our civilian Optimus so yeah we have
the pokemon wandering about the fields
we call them kind of symbol encounter so
you can see the Pokemon before you
actually encounter it but at the same
time you actually just saw an
exclamation mark pop up in the tall
grass there and that kind of simplifies
that it's a random encounter so you
don't know which Pokemon you're going to
encounter we wanted to have a mixture of
both types of encounters in these games
also let play players enjoy that
excitement of you know not knowing what
they're going to encounter yeah that's
great it looks like we've got a lot of
different types of pokémon that appear
out here in the wild area as well why
did the idea don't complete the journey
equal time you don't necessarily know
their Pokemon like the deputy on your
nose man hi so this means it's or I can
say no but Illuminati must design
Pakistani border on a Qatari States come
out what Allah beginner then there's
definitely a lot of Pokemon to encounter
and of course as you can see here the
battle system you know it's the
traditional turn-based battle where you
choose moves to defeat the wild Pokemon
before you can catch it or battle
against the preset a Pokemon vote on a
topic Sega Atari
vamos hacer cosas Medici machine all day
and I hope to sky battle tournament I
can they give me
and you'll find that they're you know
Pokemon abilities we're back as well as
the ability to give them items to hold
so there's definitely a lot of depth to
the battle system yeah certainly I think
fans are gonna look forward to the depth
within that battle system and they'll be
able to enjoy that within the game as
well as in their one-on-one battles as
well so and in multifamily become one
for you I know yeah a Pokemon from about
to the Tokyo nocturnal play atomic
solution hi and post them all thank you
to people that you know
so this nexus in the Italian study sono
Occupato resources macchiato me risotto
and a sweet potato commander filter I
carry on about Odin enough he must be
yes I definitely you can have link
battles with other players and of course
I think there's a lot of fans out there
that are looking forward to the hand of
this return of the really you know in
depth or that deep battle systems that
we have to you know really compete with
each other at all
Emami the mosquito more I know I miss
better than this from the music I play
pokemon digimon see the question your
personal think over co-op racism are a
facility you carefully about forty type
it to some other manifold came on my
taint asafoetida cumin yeah you can see
it's actually raining right now where
we're wandering about and depending on
the weather condition the kind of
certain types of pokémon will appear
more frequently right now you will see
more water type Pokemon and maybe if it
was snowing you would see more ice type
Pokemon for example
Mainichi coal rhodiola tinkled a teeny a
pharisee ayah mahkumat Sunday - idiot
aficionado muy mas and the climates
pretty dynamic so if you come back a
different day the weather may be
completely different so we really think
that players will have a lot of fun
coming back multiple times and seeing
the different Pokemon that appear
depending on the weather conditions here
so we're talking about of the different
encounters but it looks like Terry can
also whistle to attract Pokemon and
different Pokemon and have different
reactions to learn does that my income
system in the Honda shows high so the
one that took a cheaper way or so it
might go handle said hi when I'm a
sociopath so listen know okay mom
watching your face cubby I told my
prayer me to schedule a study definite
or negative
in a canister for salt on the Pocahontas
commodification descoteaux tomato Coto
de Marco tyranny or opt of the 32
Palestinian state
Maradona Pokemon today I'll quote
ability nothingness yeah the whistle is
kind of key to encountering certain
types of Pokemon for example if they're
flying high above you can't really you
know encounter them very easily so you
have to attract their attention by
whistling at them but at the same time
you like you said they're kind of
different Pokemon react differently than
some might see you whistle and run away
for example others may be curious about
you and approach you
[Music]
Terri's doing a great job of battling
and capturing pokemon here in the wild
area just got my Metapod
expanding that party right so I think
for today's treehouse live segment we're
gonna explore this part of the wild area
as we kind of head closer to one of the
towns in the game and that should give
us a good sense of this this one
particular part of the wild area but
clearly there's a lot more to the wild
area than even what we're showing here
today President Obama - Chicago no
martini much cut through my article to
the show vector in the Toronto cocktail
Navasota where daily on your internet so
this in a karateka became muslima to
show you bas Rutten optimist a motto
queenie Akiba sub-series pokemon DoCoMo
data status and my children no kimochi
no ascetic or talk we need Amita
scattered on a pokémon's commentator
here against my return another - yeah
this is just a small portion of the wild
area if you I mean if you wanted to walk
really far out there there's lots of
stuff to discover and it's you know it's
much wider there's a lot of available to
discover for example much stronger
Pokemon that you may want to go try and
seek out cold before Sagami nagaraj for
some rajasthan mosquito more Pokemon you
are a priority returning edition of BML
moon emotional day for saga me Naga
reports for the torch is occurring in
Kentucky for tamati humans
yeah we were actually just I think Terry
was showing the crouching down motion
where you can kind of get into the tall
grass and quietly approach some of the
more perhaps timid Pokemon otherwise
they might run away from you
we have talked about how when the
weather changes that specific pokémon
like appear more often so like right now
it's hailing so there's a different
variety
he might kill gossip didn't know they
took the Chico type in the Pokemon cheat
ahora thought well you know pink vulva
yukine they don't know their quarry
typhoon or Pokemon like they do nothing
yes is it snowing right now we might see
a more no more lights typo c'mon
appearing in the field and here we are
Terry taunting always picking my fights
now of course you can you can access the
wild area from very early game but as we
see here there are some rather strong
Pokemon out there okay come on the Jovan
cut out why today dia and I get on the
other one with them okay macoco they are
they beautiful
almost akin to the solid okuni you give
are talking about the EEMA Kinetico they
didn't is hard and it forever took so
you get the whole depending on where you
don't be some very high level Pokemon
that you maybe can't take on probably
run away from this one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of course what are the other things that
we saw in one of the Nintendo directs
was that to kind of help you navigate
the wild area we saw the return of the
bicycle
so the month I killed them all me dad
let's give it a [ __ ] or g10 Chaka Khan
came up Tsukiko their samyama your talk
about the family Jelena's of that so
listen if I didn't shower more a coffee
that is certainly compact for jeans and
update from 14 I do walk into the photo
a Dickens yeah I think there are a lot
of fans looking forward to the return of
the bike and it definitely helps you get
around this wide area so the to the coil
will be automatically Amano see Joanne
is no mama no little mosquito absolutely
Nico CGI resonate for your coordinator
area oh nice religion walk in silico
trade Aikido Nina there really helps you
get around the wild area very quickly
you can even hold down the B button to
kind of get a little - move going so you
get some extra speed and as you saw you
can just kind of seamlessly transition
to going above are you know on the lake
they're kind of riding over the water so
it definitely ups you get around this is
definitely a bike I wish I had when I
was younger around quickly and then of
course we also see that there's a you
know certain secrets out in the wild
area for players to find it's okay not
to the quarry taking a more normal I
also know Kira Kira - but I didn't know
which state that is Selena day oh my
knee totally the Matata of see economic
skating Authority cannot see ya every
time you come back you'll find like kind
of hidden items in different spots in
the wild there is there's a lot of fun
to walk around and discover them and of
course activities to enjoy like fishing
not on duty mowing much ah ok multiple
to say oh this city more idiot over the
kid in this kiddo not City more so much
talk to the kissing it
yeah there's definitely a lot to do in
the wild area and as you mentioned
fishing is there's one of them we don't
know Pokemon needy I don't need more
study you don't know about Pokemon debt
that is they pushing out the valence a
lot of different ways to encounter the
variety of Pokemon in the area
now one another thing that we've noticed
here on the left side is that we're
seeing some icons pop up on the left
side of the screen of a Garmin he died
in a hole in each other I know you don't
know icon but didn't escape me not - oh
God
so this in a unknown white okakura
daihama - it's gonna win it on I come on
stick Cara are in this key to move where
they are it Y by 2 into each day - Frank
I know for the city today you do not
swim also really honest with me rock
wanna eat sushi me optimist so this is
part of the new kind of communication
functionality we're calling that through
this device called the Y calm in the
games and you can actually have these
rubber calling stamps appear to kind of
show what other players are up to you ma
get support a Skype call a mahjong so
mamasan the songs get them all yo so
know it Kokomo tight till I come back
when it is a mess so this is actually a
Masuda son playing right next to us he's
playing the Gloria characters over here
oh yeah this stamp is the signifying
that he wants to trade with us
macoco de it Oh sushi in Coke and oka I
sent oka all margine yogic a guitarist a
not a bomb oxidative Otto mocha for
their yoga Kok Airport Oh ridiculous so
you can use these stamps to kind of
invite people to battle trade or even
try and get other players to join you in
a max rate okay yo dia Gloria right now
oh my you know you do not pour prayaga
Chico Mookie motion detectors in this
Kodomo sweeta a - free yoga they are
partial de Morgan's name so there's a
lot of different reasons that players
will come back to the wild area but you
can kind of encounter them other players
that are connected in the wild area in
see them in your game dr. Seuss in Dairy
Bar a tomochka Corazon de Reyes on mama
Josie sorry master see my internet
producer about because you know play da
Cunha white area they also fishing a
circuit or a deacon and this works
either would be a local Wireless with
other players that are nearby playing at
the same time you can also connect with
to the internet to kind of play with the
other players from around the world
that's right it looks like now terry has
gotten to the town that we were heading
towards right but there's some lights in
the
ground that these Red Hill area lights
could you guys explain what these are
turn off fixing on imagine Yugi moto
checks and let's get high talk to me
unalaq I know mr. Tanaka so there's not
even a Pokemon no Sudeste there are no
naka de Jujuy Kuryakin are die max
Pokemon now you must so no not power in
a Giga right okay carry the details so
those are actually what are called
Pokemon dens and there's a red light
emitting from them when there is a
Dynomax pokemon inside so the red light
kind of represents the energy of the
Dynomax burns monotony toll Moxley the
Vittorio changes acquittal ridiculous
and what that means for the player is
that you can go there and encounter that
Dynomax Pokemon in a max raid battle
well perhaps we should show the max raid
battle is like something else look we
got my bounty the bathroom or his name
to be yet to me take the blame us hi
alright so as we're popping up to decide
max rate battle mr. Mori mr. Matsuda
could you explain a little bit more to
the people watching at home about what
the Dynomax features the dynamics in
effect m osika cudoce temerity vesco
solace no no cream adidas nato machine
Kotoka de toda tu yo solo act and sk 2
moves no contact oh come on up up to the
CEO so toasty height donna ruko no die
max it is so Dynomax is actually a new
way to power up your pokemon in these
games it replaces what we've seen
previously for example mega evolution
and z moves
at OU solace NATO dyemax de votantes que
no NOS kina ate okay Mona Karen de
tráfico de víctimas de Kampala a no
boxcar amo te quiere ver no de cocora
speaker and a eukaryote Pell and
attracting you Tomas and each player
participating in the battle can choose
one Pokemon from either their party or
from the box so it's important to choose
one of your own stronger Pokemon since
you went before you go into the matter a
battle in picking on de lucha de coco
noix de keen I know they've only picket
I sit in a hot debate outside and you
only get to choose one and you can't
change during the battle so you've got
to make sure it's a good choice
communication is incredibly key here
communication today I know you need a
today's New York or even tanto thinking
a soui die Jeannie nothingness their
cooperation between the players and also
really determining the walls is gonna be
very important to defeating the opponent
Marty bar
I thought type I saw no sirree Maya he
was almost a Pokemon that - since gonna
tip for you to stay they think
University cuz it was October mark I
squatted a because I was supportive
salute Universal ties it up to me so I
want to get into the battle identifying
maybe which of the four Pokemon will
have the best type advantage to be the
main attacker and also like who can be
the best kind of support or the pokemon
that will use healing moves to support
the team yes I'm playing it's Togekiss
so for my my first move I've used this
report have used reflect to try to
protect all of us a bit close no clown
ok he saw it didn't look good knowing no
detail - they stood on the top team
wingzza much hi thank you what are the
me not sweet of glad I read a political
Koga Kega say if I put the samosa get a
thickness that'll definitely help
protect against some of these powerful
attacks
[Music]
I guess we should do roll call
I'm playing lead Akula a Ludicolo so I'm
actually just got hit and as we can see
here steelix is doing multiple attacks
is that fair to be Mahagonny oh god no
don't okay there whoa
you know that I think done this give
them a little bit of score here in this
oh no mother back to force it is my my
module curiosity but if I forget just
stick that in it smell some idea no you
don't scenario about the pit
listen optimise yeah when you're going
up against the Dynomax pokemon sometimes
they will take multiple moves and so you
really kind of can't let your guard down
digimon with their we indeed stuff there
together so thought they go gonna be
stuff so I'm I'm after the Tom character
here playing arcanine is it okay if I
use Dynomax
they muck soon under Skidmore it or cut
would pound Ethel 308 Costa my ear for
the key name isn't if they're Priya
garbage in Bonita Hawks Kenya
Martha teamocil their battle to need a
study space car they mock the beginning
of it in a day max I mean going to have
the ability to use Dynomax that actually
rotates between the players each turn
but your key you can only use dynamics
once throughout the entire battle so
it's important to kind of identify what
the exact right timing is to be able to
you know exploit the
its power so yeah they're obviously a
lot of strategy goes into these dynamics
raid battles
both all its or more pork on your big
favor you might know or know I
understand but you didn't you know you
must and yeah you can see that there are
once you dynamaxx the pokemons moves all
turn into max moves which are much more
powerful and outside these added effects
like you saw the ad route was just
triggered based off arcanine attack yeah
and they looked really cool too
don't look up we is now happy oh that's
very nice yeah definitely I think
they're very impressive as we could see
steelix just put up a barrier around
this nobody ma she did nothing today
it's what Ibiza it sounded awesome are
standing before a Mamata a drinking soy
he didn't get a turn we must put the
party on the hole so it's name hey buddy
on under Skidmore it or not Sakina body
on about a moccasin hurry the mistake
they must win to her forehead technical
so if I will just mess with the barrier
what happens is once the HP is reduced
it'll put up this kind of barrier that
you have to take down before I actually
start taking lots of damage again the
economy ma gay jjigae is it's a Denise
kiddo damage your title photo nice not
to know yes you got hit teaching us they
saw hogyoku - p4k monday more a fire
pokemon demo educated to hit Takano day
cannot achieve our Madonna Pokemon than
before if you step on a party l+ over
you just me but you can see that there's
a couple of different like parts to the
gauge and each time you hit it with a
damaging attack at least one of those
will be reduced so even if your Pokemon
isn't particularly powerful in the
attack Department it can still reduce
the gauge by just using a damaging
attack time oxwas I thought you gave it
a score politicans
well yes as you can see my night
Togekiss used dazzling clean which is
not particularly effective but was still
good enough to to break that barrier
down so it's me Mom somebody didn't
utter Hiawatha what's going on behind my
gates odw Aikido Kouga naive okay Monday
before table architects to the body
there's a good opportunity for even the
weaker Pokemon to you know participate
and really contribute to the fight and
Dynomax moves if you use it against it
it'll actually take down two gauges to
two slots of the gauge Margay jail costs
on the auto amor de cosas decade so yeah
you guys have broken down the barrier so
now you just need to defeat the pokemon
one thing that we haven't talked about
is that storm that's kind of lurking
around stealing promote you personal all
right ten called higher than and it'll
cut her arm all day masseuse star okay
more nor energy giga forces your decor
ala what it is okay
that's really the kind of the energy of
the Dynomax phenomena I'm just kind of
brewing above their head
but what's up with it plus an awesome
man looks like you're able they're
probably gonna be able to defeat this
one that's too much trouble shoot just I
said that he follow you make them what
they can totally get the center of
attention and we didn't have a single
Pokemon paint that was that was actually
pretty good
okay because it's tonight uh hi so now
all of us have a chance to actually
catch this steelix so by catching it can
we add them to our party for the short
Easter it come out a chance to God in
the killer multi I thought uh Himmel too
emotional forgiving Pacific way to
predict irritability ah ah so listen
even the Connell map come on host our
post Alma get posted Chancellor Mary
must it's come I thought became
intelligence robotics tally mark 42
yeah I'd anymore in hiding its Kamata so
yeah you can actually every player who
participates in the battle are able to
get a chance to catch it but even if you
don't catch the Pokemon there's still a
variety of rewards for the players that
participate to get items and such that
will help be beneficial in their
adventure guys you're not on that stalk
my prey homage to the heat at Sunday
were seen at the - so it's definitely
something that hope players will be
excited to play along with their friends
but also other players from around the
world yes my my daughter has really
gotten into Pokemon with Pokemon let's
go so I'm very excited to be able to do
raid battles with her in Pokemon sword
and Pokemon shield so let's go check out
you let's go EB the animals me got a
Pokemon skinny not done on the monotony
max read about everybody keep noticing
Minnesota man so I think Masuda son I
think there was another topic that you
wanted to touch on mano de apoyo de
miedo monster a mistake what about it
you know keep on hiding toto
you know something what's taste I go to
very mindful 800 K more homework well I
know
forget the monster CDs at all pokemon
born a Pokemon that tomato go to
vertices harvested a mo children also
decided to come oh then dismiss yeah
there's one thing I'd like to talk about
and it's about the Pokemon home service
that we recently announced so it will
connect with the Pokemon RPGs as well as
come on go to allow players to really
gather all of their Pokemon in a single
location and of course it will also work
with the Pokemon sword and Pokemon
shield games Tadashi put the kuda mother
Pokemon bank kono sabisu adios theta
life and Amina Fanny Santo authorized I
not very much but there is one important
change from the previous Pokemon Bank
service that I want to tell all of its
users about for the modern are don't
forget the monstrous it is about someone
they were our economy commodity night
Pokemon more material Pokemon bank
parasitic to the photo Vatican so in
previous games that worked with the
Pokemon Bank service you were able to
for example in Sun and Moon bring over
any Pokemon even if they weren't in the
aloha pokedex the hot dog on Nintendo
switching up there for can we get to
sanitation or my Shogun she time or my
journey poor youth oppinion naughty
master but with the transition to the
Nintendo switch hardware with its you
know it being much more powerful
allowing us to be much more expressive
with each of the individual Pokemon
Pokemon Madiba it's a comedy topic Oh
quite a mess and now we're well over 800
pokémon species in the games somewhat a
day titania non-curricular get a doctor
Oberon smoked a calculator makan monopod
si since a call so okay so Tommy induce
ricardinho highway Ida
you don't causality chemistry a game
freak we really spend a lot of time
thinking about what the best way to move
forward was really preserving the
quality of all the different Pokemon
while also you know taking into account
the battle balance having so many
different pokémon available all within
you know a limited development time so
we don't keep fans waiting too long for
every new entry in the series
unless I'm okay concept cut up Il
Postino
credible funny it's my style and after a
lot of discussion we decided to come to
kind of a new direction it's medicinal
Pokemon home with us although seeded oh
no I don't wanna
Corrado zucchini poses okay money see
what what is my stuff and so what that
means for Pokemon sword and shield is
that players will be able to transfer
their Pokemon from Pokemon home only if
they appear in the gala region pokedex
Sukarno Abu Tonya was it a ibogaine
booka booka nobuta yahwah's at a quota
wat a total setup okay mo kimi famous so
we were very careful we spend a lot of
time really thinking what the best
selection of Pokemon to match the
setting of the adventure would be Masada
you quazy unless you are for my loss is
like toka interview there
Santos it's in a state title means so
I'll talk more about the details and
future opportunities such as media
interviews but I wanted to let you know
today that no Pokemon bank or rodeo
stick with us after in a sign Numa it's
mostly the MacBook what stays tight I
know there are a lot of users the
Pokemon bank service who are looking for
two Pokemon homes I wanted to let them
know what the change would be well in
advance of course is somebody who's been
hunting for a lot of shiny pokemon and
pokemon let's go any of those pokemon
that do appear in pokemon sword and
shield I'll still be able to transfer
from Pokemon let's go into Pokemon sword
and shield through Pokemon home correct
my let's go Pikachu let's go you be
there on the tux on you don't you gonna
Pokemon what I stay I'm gonna come I
didn't that's good I'll put it on the
Pokemon bus home okay right I know II
know I saw this thing oh okay you states
reticle Dakota Medici
that's right yeah as long as they're in
the gala region pokedex you can transfer
them from home that's great
well oh I know what you don't miss me I
know concept in Omaha Toshiro Kirara
show them or what I mean a simple move
committee Connery no okay manga didn't
succeed come on nobody na game nobody
notice mo Canady no a commando creature
like a video Nina Jameson yeah in the
gallery region you're going to find a
lot of Pokemon including a bunch of
Pokemon that no one has discovered yet
so the games are definitely chock-full
of content the cards account with
consciousness in the more Johnny I hand
out the window scheduled non-combat
automated machine Otto omaima's
and it will be no small feat to complete
the gallery region pokedex but I do hope
the players will give their best you
know try and catch them all on the in
the region
yeah well I'm excited to see how the
story unfolds and to explore both the
region in the wild area but is there
anything else that you want to add
before we say goodbye and
and move on one he Tony Kahn kind of my
game in the story toka a white lady
hasn't answered in Roman times you mean
you didn't ask a little more mano
tips icon your thirty per annum
extortion okay turn off many go put a
while pretty much did your part so this
I killed or oxidative water all you need
in every much decade or more
I know buddy yep TT naka Cano sincere
certain or destiny more than a Pokemon
no naka de huaah not a system will not
Muslim they a party for you need a
highway tunnel school and college
station also rated tv-ma
mean assigns a he taking some alright
I'm up now for me it definitely it's the
max rate battles we just showed up
playing together with your friends and
this kind of cooperative battle feature
that we've never had in the Pokemon
series before is really just a lot of
fun I hope fans of the series will look
forward to being able to try that for
the first time the Saudis now no malaria
day no na pre-operational cocaine
studies to the not this way
para Thomas Edison a pokhara to send a
modest ozuna's Andheri antonito co Scott
Disick I do not pray Otto moderate a
Skoda Marta saying yeah Kokomo Thomas in
the marais Tanana Thomas and I even
other than the max rate battles we of
course have all the traditional
multiplayer features we can trade and
battle with other players either nearby
with the local wireless or to connect
with other player trainers from around
the world using the connecting via the
Internet great well thank you very much
for joining us today thank you all for
watching what we're gonna do is as we
get ready for our next segment here on
Nintendo treehouse live we are going to
go down to our Luigi's Mansion booth and
give you all a sneak peek at what people
are going to experience here on the show
floor it's a very very special booth so
take a quick look at that and then we
will come back in just a few minutes for
our very next segment which I think a
lot of people will be looking forward to
very much
thank you very much hey guys I'm Morgan
here with Audrey and we are haunted
hotel yeah stay calm
bill said Luigi's Mansion booth but this
is not I mean we're in the booth but
this is like a fully built out haunted
mansion which is sort of where the game
luigi's mansion three takes place I
think it might actually be haunted but
let's find out and take a look at yeah
so we just wanted you guys a home to get
a look at this this is where we've got
some players in here now but this is
when the booth opens soon we're up fans
are gonna get in here to play the game
but also be surrounded by this really
cool ambiance it's got a spooky fish
cauldron skulls jack-o'-lanterns
you know standard-issue cauldron full of
green goo and fish absolutely they're
ghosts showing up all over the walls so
be careful watch your stuff yeah and we
can see up above we've got a lot of
atmospheric stuff happening all of our
mario friends have been xed out that's
just not nice it's a little foreboding
I'm not sure if you guys are to be able
to hear the music at home and there's a
lot of sort of just sound effects
happening weird I don't even know what
kind of sounds you hear a horror movie
since Li Yuqing it's true and yes and
there every now and then you'll hear
Luigi go Mario step back here of course
you wouldn't have a haunted hotel not a
bell man yep black there's a shape back
up something hanging from the wall we
better investigate cuz that's what you
do in horror horror theme you know oh
it's fine
Morgan why did you get scared like that
I don't know I don't know just creepy
there's just things in here that yeah
things just happen it's fine for
reception best cuz we're at a hotel
again so but nobody's here Morgan that's
kind of strange
closer
well it's an abandoned Lobby here in
this haunted hotel nobody needs to worry
about any of ya got more bellman we've
got tons of creepy fog and ghosts all
over the place you can see over here
we've got all the gameplay happening
yeah oh goes just flew by us keep your
eye out there all over the place
yeah and listen really really captures
the atmosphere of Luigi's Mansion 3
maybe it's a little scarier because
you're actually inside of it yeah I'm
excited to see this place once people
get a kiss again we're inside the
convention center it is so there's so
many like blackout curtains or whatever
that I don't I do not feel like I'm
inside I feel like I mean somewhere else
completely absolutely we encourage you
to come and check this out if not we're
gonna brave this haunted hotel for you I
just saw two more ghosts run by of
course you did midair above us
[Music]
sorry people are gonna be able to check
out the game here and of course later
I'm into new tree house live at e3 we're
gonna get some live gameplay footage
yeah this game as well so please look
forward to that let's head back over
here toward these uh some of these yappy
way of ghosts again I love those sound
effects that you hear piping in all over
the place we've got coins
we've got ghoulish laughs yeah we've got
some fog there's some fog coming into
you from like I don't know where it's
gonna where it's coming from guys so
let's go back over to these these chips
over here we didn't quite get a good
look at all of them there's a
standard-issue skull on a on a I don't
know what a platter this is like a giant
it looks like a Stein I'm sure it's
delicious your legs are also glowing
there's some sort of lighting effects
normal I'm there more ghosts everywhere
you look a different ghost is popping up
it's really really cool I think we're
like this is one of those booth
experience people that come to the
Nintendo booth if they come in here
they're not gonna forget it oh no it
really is immersive you just lose
yourself in the game you're in the game
world right now
we got some cool chandelier action over
there I haven't seen GUI G yeah I feel
like not you fly through the wall pretty
terrifying
oh and that song that music yeah it's
gotta love that music whoo all right
well we're gonna see gameplay of this
later but right now we want to take it
back to the stage for the first live
gameplay of us something else completely
something much happier than this animal
crossing new horizons don't go anywhere
hey nobody wants that welcome back to
Nintendo treehouse live at e3 2019 and
what we've got coming up here is
something that I think a lot of folks
are highly anticipating yes this is the
world premiere of live gameplay for the
newest title in the Animal Crossing
series Animal Crossing new horizons
we're going to be going to into further
depth than some of the stuff that we saw
on the Nintendo Direct but also showing
off some brand new stuff so before we
get too much further I'm Sam I'm here
with Sam from treehouse also but we also
have kyogoku's on and no gummies on from
the development team to give us some
development inside thank you so much for
being here and Noriko also will be
translating so just to kick us off here
I think fans of the Animal Crossing
series who watch the direct right off
the bat notice that this time you're
setting them to a deserted island which
is quite different from the games that
we previously had the Animal Crossing
series he tell us a little bit about why
you chose a deserted island is the
setting this time in totipotency Otomo
Tanoa no Keiko up that sorry muscle he
thought so ah I know Amanda don't with
no money she needs to you know what no
Luca no money no equal stick to rigorous
your stay
Monica did a no-pressure honest with you
so V dot a nice kid Oh sweetie day
atarashi dono Moneo Takeshita da cunha
30 thanks oh no I known every day but
the catalyst ikenga looking like a boy
imagi so one of the reasons that we
thought about having the players live on
a deserted island there's actually two
main reasons and one of the reasons
being that previously in the
titles we had the player come to a
pre-existing village and then have them
start a life there and I'm from scratch
but we thought maybe we can give the
players a new experience
whoa-ah-ah-ah City Museum total animal
night approach karate yoga take with you
to Paulo de la llamada de trabajo para
Munna typhoons I see the Tammany's in
Tequesta see Nakata
natella sees in the canoe you the Utapau
anymore and not Elysee take away my
stuff and then another thing that we
thought was by giving the players a
choice a freedom to build something
there something that may add that they
may have not been able to in previous
titles that we were able to give them
that opportunity to build everything
from scratch we thought that would be a
great experience awesome and I know
folks have been waiting a long time to
get a chance to look at this title so
why do we hop right into the game I
think you folks a look cool Mickey does
like today don't worry mas so I'm gonna
start off so I think one of the things
that did to continue on what Kyogoku
some is talking about.if about expanding
the freedom animal crossing has always
been a series about freedom you could
choose to spend your time however you
want
fishing collecting bugs pulling weeds
but I think we're gonna see here is how
much that has been expanded and I love
everything about their outfits they're
ready for island life Tom Nook and Timmy
and Tommy looks so ready to go and
they're talking about e3 the the line
between the real life and Animal
Crossing life is blurring even further
you know we're watching a tanuki ki had
spirit energy image this image in Tokyo
put on me anna-san kashiyuka 39 re masa
de mama kitchen kitchen Missoula Don
Quixote to that station yeah that item
was so Tanya can go on this time around
they have a development company called
new kink and then the player is set to
be relocating to the islands through new
kinks deserted island getaway package
and then I'm Timmy and Tommy also have a
store in back to Italy a bold new
business plan I like it even when
they're in a beautiful tropical setting
thinking about the business and before
we kick off exploring too much can we
talk a little bit about what we're
seeing right here
hi need you stick I know I'm gonna tend
to hot there obviously could a co
hajimeta balcony know your tiny must
just oh I know come on tight imitating
woman's so this is where your island
life starts this is the tent that you'll
get and then we decided to put it on
beach community mother Anna hajimete
about Karina no dates and Cassini
scientists huge similar content açaí
busca Nigel Titus
so and this is how it looks inside the
tent and then we only have bare minimums
that I'm Tom Nick gave us at the moment
I think I think that's key who really
did only provide you with the bare
minimum here though I mean no matter how
humble no time they possibly only not be
masa and this time around just like
happy home designer was you're able to
move the furniture in half units around
the arm the buildings the momma Dee
oriano ji eun-ah I know here's a quarter
machine Rita's activity' Moya's and as I
think this will allow you to have more
versatility in home decoration I'm worth
mentioning here so we're not at the very
beginning of the game it's early but
when you start there's not even attempt
there no dogged a wheaty today tobacco
kids kids dr. moonda skiddo Kuno Union
Oh sweetie no hug war pedo don't go to
modica masa and as for the furniture I
think many of you have noticed in the
video but you can also place them
outside on the field so game on and a
skiddo protein Tomo who commit a shinobi
Chi in Menorca you'll even know toki wa
chigau study of eternity kena cotton the
skin okay hama be motes cut they only
and all geo any customer the kidnap team
us and and then not just a furniture but
also the tent itself you're able to
place them on the beach this is look
this was something that you couldn't
a new leaf but we're able to do that
become ke I know my Doga do me sister I
know da I know you also taught it or
email or message that so he'd only talk
okay - you're also listening and all
over that domain Ashok I stick my
Meccano here adore motherhood including
animal 9sk know much the cargo it's good
day oh they might come back to the house
today we're looking at nature she is a
taya suit you put the ultimate I don't
worry must so there are two main
elements that I want to show you one
both of them are something that you saw
in the video one of them is the DIY
recipes and then the other one is on
being able to put furniture outside so
since we're here at e3 a treehouse live
I think I want to make that as a goal
and then start doing that right now
sounds great hey MA I know you got an
excuse it's a muffin and this kid know
that can ya know da I know G boom that's
could you do this P know what
bodyguarding con una caja Rod Carew not
to Kemah title Moya mas so this is a
smartphone called Nick phone that I got
from Tom Nick and then there is a DIY
recipes app so I'm going to browse
around and look for something that I
want to make in di you I'll go disco cup
I don't know diodes cut there I know it
on a variation you know that's cool
Otsuka locota body key muscle and then
these DIY recipes include everything
from tools to furnitures and you can use
a lot of the materials that you can find
around the island Ching I mean y'know
just sort of from imaging to there no
facade are keen on the schedule just so
it's got that no DIY noncom animus um so
since we came to a deserted island there
is a lot of weeds growing around on the
island but those things can also become
a material to create something yeah it's
been - I know Casa de su marido units
tiny tamil telugu bengali tamil desu
kedo because I know it's your god a
mother who co-wrote a Meccano notes to
take title muy mas so I want to make
this walk bench but in order to make the
log bench I
some hardwood so I am going to first
make this axe so I wonder if as we're
looking around here we just take a look
at the up in the sky because it really
is a beautiful day for Monday's Godot a
noindex not akane tendo state there so
no chica except on your tips without
taking so I think a lot of the Animal
Crossing fans already know this but the
game clock is actually linked to the
real time so the seasons and the time of
the day it is it changes according to
the the clocks that you live in
mama da da da computer city nice cafe au
sweetness of the freedom okay Minami
hunk Udo exits more scent of the
curiosity until the previous titles we
only had the game set in north northern
hemisphere but from New Horizons we have
a southern hemisphere as well so the
users can play in the southern
hemisphere at atmosphere as well I put
on all thank you little cool that's not
a phone that's know who keen on the
scale or unit that's it
so right now I'm since it is June in
it's set to June in northern hemisphere
but if you have it set the southern
hemisphere then it'll be in winter it's
really cool I think being able to give
players that flexibility so if you live
in the southern hemisphere and you want
the seasons and things the weather to
kind of match more like what you're
experiencing in real life you can have
that choice and we got lucky here I
think that the weather is so good for
the stream cuz you never know what's
gonna happen Animal Crossing weather
wise but this looks gorgeous
I know oh no no died Yoga Sunday it was
to be a I was timid I don't wanna mess
that is your psyche your day with my
mood thing I know there and also go that
customer advice when you go on ice you
must so now that I have all the
materials for flimsy axe I'm gonna go
somewhere where they're gonna let me do
this for free cotton okichi touching on
I join in a team and you mean no circuit
so support us to create another super
cool been innovation in our team so this
is the resident service area by nuking
and then
for all the residents on the island with
their lives
I feel like Tom Knox always proud of you
and now Geneva
mommy kiichi Dada Lanica in a nominal
category today they spoke up and so
other functions of the resident service
I'm Timmy would buy something that you
don't mean in the inventory just so much
I thought the more I don't know they're
a new dawn appeared Otonashi we take a
testy today in this [ __ ] I'm not kidding
you strike at a lot so much it take for
the kite of tomorrow to eat don't we
so we've mentioned wheeze on the island
earlier but if you want to clean it up
then you can clean them up and then sell
it to Timmy or you can choose to leave
them as well because I mean why not
right
I kind of like it it matches the rustic
setting you're on a deserted island
having it look a little while is I cool
in contrast I picked every weed hey
what's up - hi Monica
Nikki macedonian sudanese kiddo Monica I
know I'm a bit anemic you cut the stem
you industry I know jibun de so he wrote
a side notes good demo to tear a demo an
OG&E tano Cindy does okay about on Moya
must be so as you can see you can do a
little shopping here too and then you
have the option to buy the tools
purchase the tools here as well but I
mean you can basically you'll have that
freedom of whether you if you want to
buy them or if you want to collect the
materials on the island and then make it
yourself
Damini seen on an eye on the move to
turn or to put you're taking a Tadashi
hello Kino very must accelerate upon
illuminating any muscle so one of the
new functions here is a nuke mileage
look miles
lucuma route oh you know what
man oh gee say no my dunno your knee I
know tatoeba and okay my odekake kokino
Dukakis Valesky Donna so Coconino Terry
nice camisole shopping go start oka my
mark oh no no
oh no gee such good day and on viu I -
what's good Patoka mishima day I know
Subash didn't that I can attach tomato
or a photo gotta get my suit so Nick
Maya kinda works like the actual airline
mileage programs so when we moved out
here on the airplane you got miles for
that and then a lot of the activities
that you do on the island you also
accumulate miles for that we just made a
flimsy act so we got a miles credit for
that as well and and so there's so many
ways to acquire these miles and and also
use them as well so I mean on your
homework on Okemah days
it's called tanooki mileage in japanese
because mine is you know automated - I
know you don't know service to kamikaze
and all these in a writing and Aikido no
they're from I didn't you Tomita an
authorization dosimeter also because ii
don't worry only nothing was and then
these miles are you be able to exchange
them for items and other activities so
there's it's a new way of enjoying the
game it is really nice that feels like
you can progress doing any kind of
activity do you enjoy and remember
crossing on top of it just being a fun
way if you relax you're making progress
in the game you're having a chance to
earn some of those rewards and you can
earn those rewards for doing things that
you didn't always earn rewards for
before like even just picking weeds sure
it made your area more beautiful but it
didn't really give you anything else but
now you can earn miles for that and use
them for something yeah I know cause I
was so meticulous since I now have the
flimsy axe I think I'm gonna start
collecting hard wood and here we can see
just the variety
collecting things has always been a part
of Animal Crossing but there's so many
different types of collectible crafting
materials out even looking at the wood
that you're chopping there every time
you pick something up you're gonna
wonder okay what I'm gonna do with this
what I'm gonna make with this next
question no notes katenka Cara who's out
here - kotoba Vicki Rhonda Skidmore
Choctaw no Emma I know okay chicamocha
generate a una cadena de Marco got me
some pizza that they were all don't
worry muscle so as you can see I can use
this flimsy axe to collect a hardwood
but since we have a limited amount of
time today and there's a lot of hard
wood to collect I think I'm gonna
recruit mr. negami here and have him
help me out right oh no Lucy Ricardo you
must stop anemic or item that they
appeared Scott to onaji shamanic soon
they'll join in Doshi - any police
report over to keep you anonymous so um
this is how I'm gonna do this on the
nuke phone there is an application
called call an Islander and then when
you call and I know you'll be able to
call another resident on the island and
then play together so since the gummi
son has a house on this island as well
he can come out and help out it's very
appropriate price little bit I don't
know why I'm wearing this outfit but you
know see that's a very tailored obesity
so they were hunting Mateo taking energy
muscle so I'm actually to be able to
play with your friend or family by
sharing joy clones and controllers is um
something that's very new to Animal
Crossing franchise Seema what this union
photo they don't know they know in my
mother for story due to a little bit
Sonya some demo material chica in a
pathetic consolation astonishing get at
the photo mode Aquino this kiddo Oh
genie so in the previous titles I mean
of course you were able to watch each
other play and then have fun that way
but with New Horizons you're able to
play together and
and cooperating and then so there's it's
usually a full new way of playing
together and just as you're collecting
this material here looking at the the
wind blowing through the trees the
graphics it's it's really just beautiful
to watch but I'm also really drawn to
the sound effects here and then I was
like if you talk to us a little bit
about the sound design for this game
beautiful user on all cats and you know
what's new taking on us in day to that
time you need you know the who who are
stable so there's a lot of things that
we've experimented and then we tried out
for the users to have that immersive
feeling when they're playing this game
solidity mistake
Reba no it's not only senorita are you a
small stock effectively mitigate that is
there a certain otaku and stay you did
natural not like a stainless and in
order to achieve that from the sound
perspective we adapted this technique
called Foley recording and then what it
essentially does is record a natural
sound and then use it as a sound effect
on in the game so we sometimes walked on
town as fan to get that sound or got
some some grass from around the office
and then walked on it to get that sound
yeah you did another mutant skip was a
causal yoga SP mistake and of course I
got signal calculator in unison oh thank
you God
gigs the cookie moves but I guess you're
Pouncy and another thing that you've
probably noticed is that the leaves on
the trees are kind of moving and then
this is actually expressing the wind in
on the island so depending on how strong
the wind is blowing
some of them sway a little bit harder
and the sound of the wind is really
beautiful - it's very relaxing and
immersive an event you got any Dickie
Aikido - Toma de correo de kado Asami
Shinoda Mui canonical Buddha which I
don't wash
so now I have a bench but just having a
single furniture is a little bit sad so
I think I'm gonna make something else to
it campfire motel today so not to keep
on the bonfire thing myself calm
so I'm since I already have a campfire
why don't we make a bonfire that sound
looks a little bit bigger and more fun
oh hi yeah oh yeah I know cause I out
Scott deck a mistake on my own y'know
nanika di when it's cooked acog words
got the salon it's cooler to not be iron
body muscle so bonfire you'll be able to
make that with some wood and a campfire
which is an item and there are items
where you will need another item to
create so there's a lot of variety in
these recipes don't know got me son you
know who dies she must so I'm gonna
change the leader - mister Nogami
daddy this oh no daddy needs a key so
DePodesta dhoka dhoka and what color you
need not a muscle and as you can see
there's a little flag on top of mr. no
Grammys head and then that shows that
he's the leader and then you'll be able
to tell whose feet will be leading that
gameplay are you there hey what is it
okay I'm gonna pick up the wood and then
I'm gonna go craft a bonfire on the
workbench that's one of the things
really wonderful here for the first time
in the Animal Crossing series being able
to play side by side at the same time
with other folks who live on your island
this idea that you can have your
different inventory swap back and forth
who's in charge and then take advantage
of that you can actually have up to
eight players living on a single island
and four of them can play together this
way just by sharing droidcon on the
singles
system so if you've got someone in your
family their thing is I just really like
collecting this material or that
material you can kind of share the load
a little bit as you work on your island
and then come play together you're all
enjoying the experience at the same time
and you're taking turns and trading and
making these much bigger crafting
projects but on top of that with the
folks on your Island
there's also a local wireless and online
multiplayer that we're going to be able
to talk about hopefully more later on
but with that it can be eight people all
gathering on a single players Island to
have the same kind of fun activity
side-by-side yeah the trailer in the
Nintendo Direct if you saw that scene at
the very end with all the different
players there that was actually made
using that feature oh by a big team on
Sunday
I know so busing optimization to know
Mario go kind of tiny Chaka Khan is a
hero equalizer for Yokohama Dino unique
oh no don't fight them release a team
Athena Peduto Madikeri secret a cousin
of automatic reversal so since we now
have a bonfire we are we hunted a
location misc a local haunted a location
and then decided that around the tent
will probably be the best place and then
so they're gonna decorate this area and
then mr. Kubik will also mentioned that
the there's a place an item and drop an
item option and in the players will be
able to choose whether they want to
place the furniture like decorate the
furniture or just place the leaf and
it's really incredible it opens up your
entire island really the same way you
decorated your house you're gonna be
able to put stuff in so many interesting
places and really make your island feel
like your own
yeah come knock on JD I know question
what - to lock down the - you know -
Timothy Thomas okay since we have the
location we have everything set up I
think I'm gonna take a photo I know
coming on what you don't see Chino home
tanking or the tortilla dock bottom of
the kid on the schedule smokin emo
camera goes up regarding muscle so of
course you'll be able to use the switch
function the switch camera to take a
photo but we also have a camera app on
the neck phone community telephoto day
another Moutinho dattari oh yeah no
filter in your telomere technology unit
at a time machine data that came a su
and by using this camera app you are
able to select our filters or zoom in
and out and then so you'll be able to
take photos that that you desire that
that you can decorate a little bit more
and have more freedom way since the way
to commemorate a big project or we've
got a bunch of friends hanging out with
you take a look group photo
careful no pores a lot Kimmy did you
talk to me tight on my mouth okay I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna strike a pose
and then take this photo and something
that folks maybe it's a very sharp eyed
you're noticing there's a little sort of
spot that's coming out of this and not
too far we can't really show this too
much yet but there's actually uh clams
living on the beach and if you dig those
up you can craft fishing bait using
clams so worthwhile keeping that in mind
if you're really into fishing that's
gonna be a lot of fun for folks you
wanna catch some really cool fish - a
mussel not that you need unless awesome
spouts coming out here
you know the Irish Pete do you know what
but the boots koroshite a monetary to
cut an Annika item or can even call the
Vatican Divya me okay DSP operate it
teamocil so DIY recipes you'll be
acquiring them through other animals or
and when you acquire a new item that's
something that like the that you will
also be able to acquire or you'll also
be able to buy them at stores as well I
think it's interesting how that's really
going to mix up players experiences
depending on how you and maybe a friend
of yours have been experiencing life on
your island of what activities you've
been doing you might have quite a
different collection of recipes at your
disposal so then when you have a chance
to get together and play together it
might be oh you know by the way what
have you been making what uh what did I
find this is how I got this recipe but
it's a nice way to kind of share that
knowledge of information as you play it
no animal to a single new horizon and I
only say it's nice like a dome or more
like a tie with the King Janaka
if we need meal form on the skin on it
so whatever like I have spots on your
mother mother Cory quraíanic arabic so
um see we've I'm showing you some of the
gameplay of New Horizons and if you make
things that a lot of this is close to
being done and yet there's a lot of
elements that we still want to work on
listen is your name son Oh yep
absolutely
okay they know whatever it's custom but
they must know there was that about
nothing so I'm sorry to ask but um if
you would let us work a little bit
longer
and release this game on March 20th 2020
we would very much appreciate it well I
can certainly say based on the
experiences I've had to having a great
time with this game in the office it's
very much worth the wait so I know it
folks if you're fans the game it's hard
to be patient but it's coming together
so beautifully I think the hardest thing
for me right now is working on the game
I'm just ready to get my island but
it'll be soon and your looks on do you
have any final thoughts that you'd like
to share with our viewers as well as we
wrap up high into to boot ID and each
other give Anita mood it's cozy cocoon
desu kedo no no no indeed al akhirin
what's goodness this is a geek I had to
come but the key must know that most
people show much each other care about
omoimasu so um we'll be asking you for a
little bit more time in order for us to
have you enjoy this desert out like on
an island for a very very long time so
we're all working hard to release this
game so thank you very much for your
understanding
yeah but in the meantime if you wanted
to hang out with some of your Animal
Crossing friends you could check out
Animal Crossing pocket camp on smart
devices it's free to download and
there's a lot of stuff that's been added
to that game since we released it so
please check that out but that's all the
time we have for today for Animal
Crossing new horizons thank you so much
Sam kyoko Cassano cosine and Noriko and
coming up next on Nintendo treehouse
live we got the legend of zelda links
awakening stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi welcome back to Nintendo treehouse
live dan Olsen I'm here with Audrey Sam
Noriko and mr. onuma we are going to
take a look at some live gameplay of the
new tenants which version of one of my
favorite Legend of Zelda games the
legend of zelda links awakening so Sam
please go ahead and kick us off
absolutely this is a fine fine choice
for favorite game Dan as you can see
right off the bat this is a beautifully
reimagined version of Cohill in Thailand
it looks like a clay diorama come to
life honestly is it beautiful
sorry I had to break the pot it's over
now
[Laughter]
but I love this beautiful tilt-shift
visual effect we've got going there kind
of an ethereal haze off on the corners
of the screen so it's just a really
lovely reimagining of this classic game
and since we're lucky enough to have
onuma son here I was hoping perhaps you
could tell us a little bit about the
creation of this art style and why it
was chosen to reimagine Poland Island
and once I could Akane on the other side
or not that you know dog sits nicely
tied like a master shoka
oh no oh no gamer knowledge is not about
what does your mother zeroed out to buy
a dog I'm game when I know that when I
say oh no game well quantity et user for
seducing anatomists intimacy and so
actually this game I wasn't actually
involved in the creating it
I was just a player playing this game
the doggy
I told you man game the boy there us on
the back it asked a dog I know poor game
was moving at CSUN economy garage and
also no it was just an eco hero a stager
hero not tell me Tyler so 9 is a 2008 on
the schedule
so no can't go Noah Casa de Thursday
anoche little shift opt met Anna gammon
no we had to study for Tom Baca Baca her
sister buscadordeauto.com miniature no
Joe Aleman second also heated Medina
Sona can you imagine e Navi only head
and so when I played it on the original
game boy version it was in this small
screen and it felt like a small world
but there
vast as well and so it was kind of had
this tilt-shift
perspective and so that's why I thought
this miniature diorama like art style
would be perfect for this game it really
is the perfect way to bring this world
to life and so I'm going into the trendy
game shop here and even fans who played
the original game are going to notice a
little bit of a difference here because
their actual real cream physics going on
here so I'm going to try my best to get
this Yoshi figure but it's pretty
difficult with the crane yeah the crane
physics make this a lot more fun I think
and speaking of Yoshi's looking good
I might be okay that's not a face that
you usually see in Celtic games so since
we have Dan here who worked on the
original localization of the game
perhaps you could just really quickly I
want to ask Dan what it was like to see
a Mario face in his old a game for the
first time well I was surprised as
anyway you know I think the team was
trying to create sort of otherworldly
atmosphere and bringing in some things
that would make people kind of wonder
you know what's going on here yeah I
think that adds to the mystery of the
story and and is really like a great
feature of this game and I think really
makes it feel like a different world
yeah absolutely it really does and like
we said this is a true I'm gonna try and
get that heart one more time I'll make
people watch me keep going this really
is a truly classic Zelda game brought to
life so I was hoping all new Masson to
tell us when it was like returning to
more traditional Zelda game after
working on The Legend of Zelda breath of
the wild the bristles of our dog
accomplished Mr Mcoy identity
conejito chemist ashoka mukpo Nagamani
zero payment stratagem anandamaya annal
nathrach lyrics camera he takes that up
there it's comedy major sign up you know
motive ampicillin and so the original
game boy version was released 26 years
ago so it's a little bit hard to get
your hands on the original game so I've
always wanted to remake this title and
we're so under schedule but it's uno it
was Illinois you know my identity Gina I
know as we all think of as a day I no
matter who you name a dental Tecna and
all digital game anymore to see senator
machine the more air in Jamaican optimal
even in Exeter Sundays
and so why now you might ask it's just
because we thought well breadth of the
wild broke the convention of Zelda and
now because a lot of people have played
breath of the wild they could go back to
something a more traditional Zelda like
Link's Awakening and we hope that this
gameplay will be fresh for people it
absolutely feels brand new I played
Link's Awakening probably a million
times but this new game it's absolutely
delightful and so um now that I somehow
managed to get that Yoshi doll out of
that game game I'm gonna chop all the
graphs in the world
no I'm not really this Yoshi doll is
actually a part of a pretty vast trading
quest in writing so I'm gonna go into
this house which I love looking around
there's so many little details in this
house there's like chopped up piece of
fruit on that cutting board
all these little beds in a row I love
how they're all bunched up together I
suppose if you want to get into the one
at the very end yes get in the first one
and just roll all the way over
absolutely so before I do this lady a
favor
but I'm doing her a solid here so it's
fine in a breaker pots there are things
that are baby and then give her Yoshida
a fair trade I suppose absolutely
and so in exchange for that I got a
ribbon and then I can exchange the
ribbon with someone else in this world
so everybody wins
so I know that Audrey touched on a
little bit earlier with Dan but Dan you
did work on the original localization
for this title yeah and this world is
filled with all kinds of different
charming and quirky characters and and I
was wondering if you had any particular
favorite it's really hard to pick a
favorite because there's so many I was
trying to think of a good answer for
this and when I could remember was that
alligator named sail I don't know any
stuck in my mind but I just thought it
was very funny that there was an
alligator named sail who would tell you
things but I want I'm curious with I
don't know my son's favorite characters
yeah hi so when you ma come in you must
give me the Guam due back
I know Temari only difficulty
characteristic Oh Antonia no leader